more than a month after police searched
a northwest valley restaurant the health
district is allowing it to now reopen
secret of siam was temporarily shut down
last month after more than 30 people
reported getting sick madison kimbrough
was there live tonight madison any idea
of when that restaurant might be able to
reopen
[Music]
denise that's still unknown but as you
can see there's a lock still attached to
the door but with the health district
giving the restaurant the green light to
open people who live in the area have
mixed reactions
there was just a thread that was started
by some concerned people anytime you
hear about something like that i
wouldn't want to take a chance i have
kids you don't want to put your family
at risk that next door threat spreading
like wildfire as more and more people
claim to be ill after eating its secret
of siam thai cuisine those claims were
originally made in february and now over
a month later the health district is
allowing the restaurant to reopen
releasing a statement wednesday
specifying conditions for the reopening
and while some people in the area don't
care to dine at the thai restaurant
after what happened several say they
feel this was an isolated incident i
hear it's a good restaurant because
people like eating here and they're very
comfortable here
so i think it would be great if they did
reopen i wouldn't mind trying it if they
reopened
and they were up to code i've heard
really good things and i know how hard
it is to
run and maintain and own a restaurant
and i'd like to support a local business
metro police stating that there was no
criminal intent behind the ordeal and
that the case is now closed also
confirming that the illnesses were due
to contamination from tainted
ingredients purchased through a third
party
and we reached out to the restaurant
directly we also called the owner but no
response still no word on when the
restaurant will officially reopen
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now